I want to thank you all for joining us
um for our crispr 10 years of genome
editing and more webinar today today I
have Dr Michael Snyder with me Michael
Snyder is the Stanford asherman
professor and chair of genetics and the
director of the center of genomics and
personalized medicine
Dr Snyder received his PhD training at
the California Institute of Technology
and carried out postdoctoral training at
Stanford University he's a leader in the
field of functional genomics and
proteomics and one of the major
participants of the encode project
his laboratory study was the first to
perform a large-scale functional
genomics project in any organism and has
launched many Technologies in genomics
and proteomics that have been used for
characterizing genomes proteomes and
Regulatory networks Dr Snyder thank you
for being with us today
great fantastic okay well it's wonderful
to be here and tell you some of the
things that's going on with crispr so uh
as as was mentioned we're somewhat
celebrating 10 years of genome editing
crispr as a phenomenon was actually
discovered uh in the 80s mostly as a
genetic Locus they didn't know what it
did and it took a long time to figure
out what it did but really uh about 10
years ago is when it exploded as an as
an incredible technology for being able
to edit our DNA and it's really had
profound consequences on on many areas
of biology and we'll talk about some of
that so specifically what we're going to
go over well I should mention I have a
lot of conflicts
um so um because I found a lot of
companies uh and uh also I'll mention
that if you do want to learn more as was
mentioned earlier if you take care
Christopher course and even our genetics
certificate program genetics and
genomics so here's what we're going to
cover today we're going to talk a little
bit about what is crispr we'll spend a
fair amount of time on its current uses
in medicine and agriculture Etc uh we'll
talk about some of the you know ethics
and and things you might consider where
this field could go and its
possibilities we'll just touch briefly
on how this technology can be used in
incredible research advances and also a
bit in in future directions
all right so what is crispr well crispr
um stands for this long name clustered
regulatory regularly interspace short
pound drum like repeats and I'll show
you just a little more on the next slide
basically it's some repetitive sequence
it was discovered as this genetic Locus
as I say nobody knew what it did
in the end it turns out to be it's a
antiviral defense system that bacteria
use to actually block wipe out viruses
that try to invade them
um and and I'll show you that in a
minute as well and relevant to today's
talk it's really emerged as an
incredible tool for editing DNA and much
much more as indicated here
so basically here's how it was
discovered people were sequencing and
looking at loci and bacteria and what
they discovered was there's this crispr
Locus which has these repeats that's
actually this bluish purple thing here
and then there were these spacers in
between that were unique sequences uh
flanking this and these turn out to get
expressed as RNA meaning your DNA for
many of you know that makes RNA of these
things which later will get processed
into these sort of repeats with these
spacer elements next to them
but also in this Locus are a set of
genes that are actually quite important
as well that are actually important for
the cleavages we'll talk about in a
minute so this thing itself believe it
or not came from a bacterial virus they
call them bacteriophages but from uh it
was adapted from that and then in the
end to choose actually as a viral depend
defense mechanism for bacterias what
happens is when other viruses come into
the cell they have homology to the
spacer elements here the this crispr
system besides you a key set of proteins
here plus this this RNA if you will
actually attacks it and destroys it okay
so it's an antiviral strategy that
bacteria use to protect themselves
and of course then um
it's it's got an adapter it's gotten
adapted to be able to actually
re-engineer genomes because this idea
that you could cleave DNA turns out to
be very very powerful and and the reason
it works so well is it's just incredibly
efficient
and so in the latest rendition this is
how things got adapted and this I should
point out is what led to a Nobel Prize
uh two years ago for Jennifer doudna and
Emmanuel
um carpente
um so they they basically uh set up this
system and really what it involves doing
is it's a single protein system and the
protein is kind of famous now it's
called cas9 it's a part of this
Christopher Locus and together with this
what was the repeated element now it's
sort of engineered in its new way and
very specific sequence called a guide so
this was originally set up to destroy as
I say bacterial viruses but you can
actually set it up and with a sequence
that's actually homologous to any region
of DNA you want to modify and so what
what's done is these are called guide
rnas you have a Seek part of the
sequence of homologous to the region you
want to modify and together with some of
the key recognition sequencing that's
recognized by cas9 and together this
guide RNA plus cas9 will lead make a
double strand of break here so it's just
two components you need again the
protein is this cas9 and this what's
called guide RNA and so the way this
works uh um is that you would actually
get this in the cells would go through
this more in a minute and if you can get
the protein pluses guide RNA what it'll
do is it'll go find its Locus where the
region where it's complementary to and
it Cleaves it and if you don't have any
other sequences what will happen is
it'll it'll cleave that Locus and then
your your cells try and repair that and
they don't do it perfectly they tend to
actually leave out base it gets chewed
up a little bit and so they'll you'll
make one to three base deletions
sometimes a lot larger and basically
that winds up creating a mutation it
gets sealed back up and usually you get
mutations that's the most common are
deletions of of some key basis so this
actually then can modify any Locus you
want
now this isn't it has some use but it's
not as useful as if you can make a very
specific modification and so it's been
adapted one more time where you actually
do the same thing but instead of just
letting it repair itself you add uh
what's called a template you add the
sequence you would like to see get
replaced and then instead of the other
thing was called non-homologous and
joining for the aficionados out there
but well what will happen here is that
you can use homology the the
complementary sequences I know this is a
little sophisticated for some of you who
don't have a strong background here
that's guess that's why you would take
our program but basically what will
happen is if you give it a sequence you
want to fix say you have a an original
mutation in this Locus you can put in
the normal sequence so and with this
crispr system you can repair it so you
basically go back in and you'll take a
piece of DNA and fix it and so that's
extremely extremely powerful and so
that's what's been done it's been done
in lots of cells and and you'll see in a
minute in organisms and stuff as well
all right so here's how you do this you
actually uh would take a a region you
want to to modify and you you would
actually have this homologous sequence
together with the guide sequence and
then also the cas9 protein you you would
either embed this thing you can encode
it this this thing into a a virus and
their ways of doing that say
lentoviruses or or AV or other kinds of
viruses things actually believe it or
not we go through in our certificate
program and uh or you can use these days
some of these they're called nanopartis
these lipid embedded particles these are
things they use for vaccines now coveted
and such and either way you can coat the
the key elements here and transfer them
into cells and so those will go inside
the cell and then they'll edit the
genome and the way I just described and
then make sure it's right that you did
make the right correction you actually
would determine the sequence of that
reach and make sure everything is what
you thought it was and so it works and
and what's special about this crispr
cast system as they call it is that it's
extremely extremely efficient
and it often works not just on we have
two copies as you may know of all of our
DNA one from our mom one from her dad it
often fix it on both copies not just one
so it's very very powerful
so
um basically then as you might imagine
this has been used a lot it's used in a
lot in research re-engineering cells for
studying biological systems and there's
a ton of activity there I'll mention
some of this at the very very end but
it's being used a lot in medicine as
well and and I thought I would review
some of the applications for that here
and then that'll leave us lots of time
for questions by the way at the end and
so basically it's turned out to have
very profound uh implications on all
kinds of areas of medicine and I'll run
you through a few examples there's now a
number of Trials out there using crispr
certainly the most advanced trial is
actually to fix a disease that's
reasonably common called sickle cell
disease it's really very prevalent in
certain parts of the world and in
African Americans as well in the in the
United States uh and and in other groups
as well and also there's another related
disease called thalassemia that's also
red blood cell disease and these folks
they basically have a mutation in in a
hemoglobin Gene it's an important part
of your red blood cells your hemoglobin
as you probably know it carries oxygen
that's any red blood cells carries
oxygen all your tissue is really really
important to oxygenate all your cells
and people have the sickle cell disease
they basically their cells they don't
work as well as the bottom line and the
cells get into shape and as shown here
they'll actually you know become stiff
and block blood vessel what have you and
and it can be some forms are very mild
some forms are pretty extreme and so it
turns out there's two ways that people
have been trying to fix folks with this
and one is in the in the basically in
the stem cells if you will you can
actually remove there's two tricks one
is that the latest is actually trying to
fix the mutation itself if you see them
mutation you go in and try and fix them
that's being done here at Stanford by
Matt porteous another trick that people
use believe it or not you actually have
two forms of hemoglobin you have one in
when you're a fetus and then you have
another one once you've been born it
switches this one form of hemoglobin to
another from what's called fetal
hemoglobin to the adult form and nobody
knows why we have those two but it's we
we do and basically you can actually
instead of directly trying to fix the
adult form you can just leave the feet
make the fetal form active and so you
can basically inhibit or remove the gene
that turns this thing off and so the
bottom line is that the trick here is
that you just leave this fetal either
fetal hemoglobin on or you fix the
mutation here and it turns out from
preliminary trials their numbers are
still small one trial had about 14
people another had Somewhere Only half a
dozen and they're a little further along
now but it turns out it works it works
um and enough to get roughly 30 to 40
percent normal levels of hemoglobin and
that's enough actually to fix people you
don't need a hundred percent to fix
people so so so far the data are very
very encouraging and so this looks this
looks starting to look pretty good so
they call this thing xvivo because
you're actually fixing a person's stem
cells outside of their body you collect
their stem cells fix them and then you
return them back with these
modifications okay and it works pretty
well
so this is now being considered for many
other things a very related conditions
called beta thalassemia it's also a red
blood cell disorder but then there's
some other very very debilitating
um I'm sure you know
um disease as well the Shen muscular
dystrophy uh and and some of these other
things again that are listed here this
one's in the affects the eye this one's
a nerve and heart disease that's amyloid
is affecting nerve cells and and people
are trying these as well but people like
to actually try to fix the eye for a lot
of reasons uh first of all it turns out
it's fairly isolated from your immune
system it's an ideal area where people
try Gene therapies a lot and also a lot
of people have some severe problems with
eyes so uh and and to cure blindness is
a big deal so anyway there are people
are actually trying to do these
Corrections if you will uh for each of
these different diseases and these
trials are on the way there's quite a
few different trials there's a lot of a
lot of other
things where people are very interested
in yet that haven't quite reached trials
or maybe they're just starting uh I
think most of these have not started yet
but people would like to there's early
forms of Alzheimer's that if you can fix
that would obviously be huge people get
Alzheimer's you know very young age say
30s or 40s cystic fibrosis you may know
is relatively prevalent Huntington's is
an absolutely incurable disease as it
currently exists so to be able to fix
this would be huge Tay Sachs also as far
as I know no known cures and fragile so
so being able to go in and manipulate uh
the the genetic regions responsible for
these diseases would in fact be a huge
huge deal and there are other ways of
treating for certain forms of cystic
fibrosis but not for most forms actually
right most those others are not curable
uh so the these single gene mutations
that I mentioned before people are
trying to fix uh turns out crispr is
also being used for cancer and this gets
a little complicated again we cover it
somewhat in our in our course uh but
crispr it's being used a ton of basic
research for cancer so manipulating
cells manipulating mice to be able to
study models of cancer but it's actually
being used in patients now so some
trials have started here and there's
several versions of this one what you
can do is it turns out cancer cells are
very clever they've come up with a way
of of sort of a don't eat me signal that
that basically means that their their
immune system is a special set of cells
called t cells cancer cells make a
protein on the surface that is
recognized by these T cells and says hey
I'm self you you shouldn't eat me you
shouldn't attack me and so that they've
figured out how to get around their
immune system by doing just that um so
when you get cancer they figured out how
to basically block your immune your
immune cells from attacking them and so
um they're ways of tricking than this to
get back and try and re-engineer T cells
to be able to attack them one way to do
this is to get rid of that signal here
if you don't have the signal this thing
will cancer will look as far look like
foreign cells in your T Cell will
actually destroy it so the trick here is
to actually get rid of this protein here
pd1 there's another kind of um protein
out there too they call these
checkpoints that actually they keep
things in check and prevent things from
from eating them but you can modify
these uh and so uh either by themselves
and these days there's also another
genetic trick to use where actually can
promote the attack of these cancer cells
and and this one definitely uses crispr
and this one usually uses Gene Edition
but can involve modification using
crispr as well so the point out of all
this is that we can now treat cancer
using some of these same Technologies
again very very powerful
people are talking about trying to use
this to try and block viral infections
so just like the original idea with
bacteria imagine you have
crispr sequences embedded in some of
your cells and this is being used for
HIV by the way uh where you would
actually well for this case the idea is
you would actually have these uh crispr
rnas all set up to attack if you will
SARS cov2 now this uses a little bit of
a trick it doesn't Cyrus is an RNA virus
so you actually have to have there's a
new kind of crispr out that actually
attacks RNA it makes mine so the the
idea here is that you would use this new
system to block SARS but people are
actually talking about modifying
um your cells to be able to you you may
know there's a receptor on your cells
for HIV so when people get HIV
this virus spreads throughout their
immune cells because of those receptors
because the C cr5 so we were actually
talking about and and there are trials
underway as mine are seeing to eliminate
that so that
um uh if you get rid of that then HIV
can't spread and you actually get some
good immune cells to help uh protect
yourself so that's being explored as a
very interesting possible therapy for
um you know at least reducing HIV and
coming up with a set of very good immune
cells so HIV folks can have a good
immune system
uh it's not just humans people are
talking about doing this there's wide
potential in agriculture we run a a
biotechnology course in our in our
program and you can read all about all
the different ways you can manipulate uh
agriculture there's a lot of very clever
and some of this is already being used
for making
um you know weed resistance uh and and
actually improving the nutrients within
within food people are talking about and
what's special here and also I should
say um turns out preserving uh fruits
and vegetables a big deal 30 to 40
percent of fruits and vegetables spoiled
they never get uh into a stomach they
just they a lot of them die and
Transplant they're a spoil and then a
lot die in your fridge so really if you
can make things resist and there are
tricks for doing this from manipulating
some of the signaling things that
actually lead to resistance and and so
people are talking about trying to again
do food preservation to make better
nutrients so antioxidants
you know in general as you get older you
have more oxidative stress so the goal
is have more antioxidants God is an
interesting molecule Pro vitamins things
like that and one important Point listed
here is that what's different about this
from say adding genes through viruses
and things that actually modifies the
the the plants so if you do do and same
with humans if you do viral addition to
get things in
that is that's considered uh a more
serious Gene manipulation whereas if you
actually do Christopher cas9 you don't
leave any viral sequences behind if you
use those nanoparticles and so what
you're doing is you're able to modify
the genome by and you're not adding any
exogenous things like viruses and things
they've had people worry your immune
system is going to attack it so they're
generally not considered GMOs if you use
this technology because it's a lot
cleaner and so these are some of the
things that have been manipulated in the
past and some of this I should say is
for actually getting resistance to
viruses that plant viruses that attack
and Destroy these two
so it's another finally there's all
kinds of clever other ways to use crispr
I think one of the most uh interesting
one right now it's very very topical
some of you may have just seen this but
uh people obviously want to control
mosquitoes and uh mosquitoes I'm sure
you know they carry very nasty pathogens
malaria less Nile Virus zika and malaria
in particular and and has been you know
a rage for much of the uh a planet for a
long time especially tropical areas and
uh you know it's been hard to eliminate
and and so people use nasty you know
pesticides things like that and nobody
really wants to use those chemicals they
have other side effects that aren't so
great and they're very non-specific they
don't just wipe out mosquitoes they wipe
out tons of stuff
it's one of the very very clever ways to
use is actually the most common way is
using this one here
is actually you can still sterilize mail
some mosquitoes tend to mate once
females do and so what you can do is you
can use crispr cast 9 to sterilize the
males and then actually they'll mate
with the females who then won't mate
again because the males were sterile the
females don't have
uh you know mosquito babies so to speak
they don't make larvae and such and so
the net result is that you can actually
reduce population so there are trials
running right now in fact there's I
forgot how many it's just a huge number
of mosquitoes they're releasing right
now in the Florida Keys that are
manipulated this way and even in
California where we are it's actually uh
now trials are about to launch in both
these two sites using very very large
numbers of mosquitoes so they run pilots
on this before these are these are
considered Pilots as well larger pilot
and so this would this likely will
reduce the the mosquito population size
and therefore hopefully release these
things without wiping out all insects it
would be very very specific for very
specific class of mosquitoes one
particular kind of mosquito is the major
culprit in this okay and so this is uh
this and there's there's even some other
tricks you can use something called Gene
drive to try and actually drive it even
further
so anyway these are some of the clever
ways in which you can use this and then
uh but it does raise questions some of
you might be thinking about right now
all right so we can go around and modify
people's DNA
well should we do this is this a good
thing to do and and nobody's going to
argue with modifying life-threatening
diseases I think we all would agree that
that's a good thing but what about other
things and and some people say well you
know if we can figure out genes for
intelligence we we can't right now very
well we don't have should say strong
genes for this and they're complicated
so it's not usually single genes uh but
you know should we go around and modify
all this and so again I don't think
anybody's going to have a hard time with
with
nasty diseases trying to fix them also
if you fix them somatically meaning not
in the germ line but like I mentioned
fixing people's blood uh that's
perfectly fine it's not going to pass on
to the kids uh you're going to hopefully
cure the person that's all good and
exciting again totally non-controversial
what about going into the germ line to
start changing things so future
Generations might be affected and what
if some of these things you know it's we
don't know 100 exactly when you start
buggering up people's genomes are we are
we causing issues we don't know about
and so people are are very cautious
justifiably so about what you can and
can't do here also I should point out
the technology it's gotten pretty good
lately but people still worry about
what's called off Target effects you're
trying to manipulate a specific Locus
but with some low frequency you often
get changes elsewhere in people's DNA
and what if while you're trying to fix
one thing you create a problem somewhere
else and that has happened by the way in
genetic engineering before we're trying
to fix uh someone's immune system has
led to an increase in cancer for example
in one kind of trial and that that's was
uh that required a lot of reworking to
figure that out so so we want to make
sure we get it right at things working
well but uh there have been you know
there was a case not long ago
um where a person in China it wasn't a
legal what he did he went in and
modified uh three embryos human embryos
actually one was twin girls and another
was a from another family and this is
the age receptor the ccr5 the hiv-1
receptor and genius and so
um he went in and modified this Gene the
father had AIDS and his argument was
well this will help protect the kids
from getting AIDS a lot of people felt
it wasn't necessary because there are
other ways if he could have these kids
and they wouldn't necessarily they were
in vitro fertilized they got the embryos
so it wasn't the it's not clear 100 you
had to do this but uh he it since he
jumped up at a meeting and presented his
results from these first twins and it
really exploded into a a big controversy
almost everyone blasted him because of
the time the technology was still new it
wasn't clear how much there were these
off-target effects it really created a
big stink um but there was one uh very
prominent scientist today what he did is
perfectly fine uh you know he's trying
to actually help these this family and
and you know have girls that won't get
AIDS uh which you know was the main
argument of this this fellow here in the
end he uh um some created a big
controversy with most people weighing
severely against him uh because he he
did kind of do it he made he wanted to
make a big splash um and uh he did and
uh in the end though he actually did
wind up in jail because he the way he he
ran the study he a lot of it was
unethical he didn't quite notify the
family quite right he didn't his mind
understanding and he uh he he wasn't
completely honest there's always review
boards whenever you do uh with when you
work with human subjects you have to get
approval and get everything tidied up
nicely and and he
was accused of not doing that so he did
wind up in in jail for three years just
got released this year so anyway but the
point out of all this is that um first
of all this is the real deal this we
will be editing people uh and certainly
again somatically and not in germline
that's that's it's a no-brainer but in
germline there will be a time when we
will be editing people and so the
question is what's the right approach
how do we make sure it's safe all these
things and so there'll be committee set
up and guidelines to be able to do this
in a responsible fashion
I will say though that then as a
research tool crispr again has just
exploded I talked about modifying DNA
but it turns out there are versions of
this I alluded to this where with this
one cast 13 you can actually modify
directly modify RNA now that's kind of
interesting because if you modify RNA
you're not changing germ lines and there
are many applications where this could
be very very favorable you don't have to
worry about causing cancer because it's
temporary when you go around start
modifying RNA
in there are other ways that this is
used for research purposes you can
re-engineer these guide rnas to be able
to bring in inhibitory proteins or
things that will directly modify your
DNA like DNA methylation change What's
called the epigenome there are other
kinds of ways of using this technology
as well uh and and so it's it's just
exploded it's turned into an incredible
um uh
tool to be able to use them many many
different ways for helping us understand
their genome modify the genome to look
at effects
most things that will involve like
medical purposes will probably sit
around modifying DNA and RNA but for
research purposes there's many many
different ways to use this
future directions well everything I just
said it's still the early days we're
going to see a lot more of this for a
cancer Therapeutics uh gene therapy
methods you know we're in a world where
we have to figure out how to feed the
planet and being able to increase yield
get disease resistant
plants and and food is a big deal for us
as a as a you know as a human
civilization and so we really will need
to improve all that and so there will be
ways of doing all this and I mentioned
even well it will impact climate climate
is getting more severe and so having
drought resistant plants and things like
that will be a very very big deal
so that's really uh what I want to tell
you about crispr I know it's kind of
just a light touch on all this uh you
can dig deeper in this program the
genetics and genomics certificate
program teach about genetics sequencing
Technologies all kinds of fun stuff uh
including biotechnology that I alluded
to here and don't forget our new crispr
course which you can take as well
we're Fielding questions here and we can
start with the first one let me begin
with the first question Dr Snyder which
is how do we ensure crispr cas9 goes to
and edits the exact spot in the DNA
yeah it comes down to designing the pro
these these guide rnas just right they
really like to Target their target
sequence and initially when the
technology was set up they would do that
but they would also recognize related
sequences around the genome it was quite
imperfect but they the systems have
improved a lot they've evolved a lot of
these systems either grabbed a better
High Fidelity proteins uh and improve
the technology a lot so actually the
number of off-target effects is very
very low
and so
um it's it's quite minimal these days uh
is it low enough to go ahead and start
modifying people's germline
um that will be open for discussion it's
a great question
the next question is how do we ensure
the virus isn't detrimental to the cell
and how do we make sure it just acts as
a transporter
yeah good question so there's a lot of
work around this kind of thing for
transferring uh using viruses for
transferring and in general people think
a certain kind of virus we have a gene
therapy module in our in our program
called aav it generally some of the
latest versions are thought to be fairly
safe but having said that people I think
to get around that are using these
nanoparticles same things used for
vaccinations they're so they have zero
viral sequences they're more lipid
particles for actually doing the
transfer and so that becoming the more
preferred route for actually
transferring crispr sequences and
protein
great thank you
next question coming up here is could
you talk about how crispr regulations
are evolving and are some countries more
restrictive than others
uh uh yes now I don't know it's evolving
so fast I can't say I know everything uh
in the U.S there clearly are guidelines
for all this and you can't use federal
money so a lot of a lot of research
that's been supported is in fact
federally funded so you can't use it to
go around and start manipulating human
embryos and things uh so
um and and you know make babies and
stuff that that's just not allowed yet
so I I think there there are these
oversight boards so the US I think
Europe is pretty restrictive and in
general there's been these guidelines
these like the stem cell and other
groups have set up Global guidelines
although it doesn't mean in certain
countries people have to pay attention
to those so it is possible to go off the
grid if you will and do these sorts of
things and and uh it's conceivable then
that in certain countries people will go
charge ahead uh with perhaps a little
less care than we're trying to do in the
US so and I don't think there's a whole
lot you can do about that uh you know I
I would hope that in general scientists
would be safe and very responsible uh in
executing this technology and so I and
General I think people are discussing
you do get approval for any experiments
you do
and you get them reviewed by an Ethics
board and such and so there's a lot
there's a lot of checks and balances in
the U.S system and in Europe for making
sure this proceeds very responsibly
right and then
um as a follow-up question
what is the biggest hurdle to using
these Technologies broadly
well these days they are reused quite
calmly I again I would say uh for a
somatic changes it's um it really is
being used now they are a bit expensive
it's kind of expensive to go in and take
out your bone marrow cells and change
them these there's a certain kind of
immunotherapy called carth car T believe
it or not that costs about a between a
half a million and a million dollars per
treatment
it's huge so you could argue there the
cost is kind of high but as we get
better and better at this the costs have
a way of dropping and so I think most of
us are optimistic that as things move
forward costs will get more efficient
costs will drop and it would be
wonderful if everybody could treat their
own individual cancer by manipulating
their immune cells and that is a
distinct possibility in the future of
that but that may happen I think there's
a ton of Interest many of you may know
in in improving longevity and health
span and and you know where people will
be thinking about ways of manipulating
the genome to do that no question now we
don't know how to do that right now so
it's not an issue but there will be a
time when we will
so uh the biggest barrier uh on one hand
I would argue it's the regulation and
ensuring this technology is safe to use
again zero off Target effects it would
create you'd hate to go around and try
to curse uh you know a future generation
of a problem and then discover you
created another a problem of its own so
I I think making sure the technology is
safe using it responsibly those those
are limiting and then costs in some of
the cases I mentioned
great questions
the next question is why are there not
more active commercial applications of
crispr out there already and what needs
to happen to expedite such breakthroughs
no I think there isn't a lot of
companies out there not to worry
so uh feel free to Google it up I've
lost track there's so many companies out
there and every one of those
applications I mentioned there's a a
company here behind it sometimes too so
there's I I didn't present every
um a lot of people are doing
um what's called pre-clinical so when
you actually start using these as
therapies you first you usually show it
works and cell lines and then show it
works in animals and people typically
start with small animals like mice and
rats and then later they'll move to dogs
and sometimes primates depends on the
therapy you're trying to exit so you
actually have to go through all those
steps typically before you start uh you
know putting things in humans people
want to make sure it's safe now the
tricky part is what works in mice or
rats doesn't always work in humans so
there the there is some painful parts to
this whole process and so a lot of
things will you know as as someone likes
to say we've cured cancer you know a
million times in rats uh but we still
have a long ways to go in humans so uh
anyway there's all just a lot of
pre-clinical work there's a ton of
activity there are a ton of companies uh
and then a fair number I I gave you just
the tip of the iceberg I can we can send
around a web link where they'll they
talk about all the existing trials or
trials are about to come uh using crispr
technology it's it's skyrocketing but
especially when consider say three years
ago I believe there were probably very
few if any trials so we it's really
mushrooming in a big way
in your opinion our crispr edited plants
safe is our next question
are they plants of yeah I think so I
mean again you're just manipulating the
DNA uh and you're doing the same thing
you'd probably do with genetics but
instead of selecting strains which is
very very painstaking uh you can go in
and directly Target make the changes you
want so in my opinion they're quite safe
I've never heard of anyone harmed by uh
even even when people have done genetic
manipulations of plants to make them say
viral resistant or uh climate resistance
say to drought and things uh no one's
ever been hurt by that so I'm I'm a big
believer that biotechnology is generally
safe you you want to watch and make sure
that you don't make a plant that then
you know takes over like everything
that's not good but as far as human
consumption I've yet to hear any
manipulation that has adverse effects
thank you
next question is are there any trials
for lipid metabolism disorders for
instance PKU is in trial is that correct
uh I don't know about that particular
one it's possible again there's a lot of
Trials out there now and I don't I can't
say I know everyone I'm not aware of
that one but it wouldn't surprise me
and then is there a stance by the way so
this is an example like an Olympic
metabolism whoever asks us may know this
but a lot of people have high
cholesterol and there are actually
therapies using monoclonal antibodies
fractures driving that town it's called
pcsk9 Inhibitors and and they work quite
well I'm actually on it works incredibly
well so
um anyway just uh a thought there so
um so therefore the need for
manipulating someone's DNA
um especially when we're not sure it's
safe is a is less obvious
is there a stand
scientific Community has on the Patrol
you
'd in terms of editing
yeah it's a good question I think in gen
it's a great question actually in
general
life-threatening diseases people don't
have a a problem with although it's
interesting because
uh you know what might seem
life-threatening some cases for example
Sickle Cell gives some protection on
malaria and people wondered whether some
of the cystic fibrosis was giving
protection you know in ancient times on
things like TB and stuff it's not clear
but so you do wonder if you when you're
trying to solve one problem whether
you're you're creating a different
problem that that has to be thought
through but as a general I think for
correcting severe diseases people don't
have a problem with I I think you know
uh I personally don't see the point in
in correcting you know trying to improve
intelligence hype this kind of thing uh
it's that's getting into a very dicey
area you know I do think it's an
interesting question to debate what
about people of short stature and they
were their parents want to make them
larger you may know that we do human
growth hormone rejection from folks is
is that ethical or not and some people
say look my kid will be entirely
stigmatized if he winds up at four foot
six
uh uh amongst all his classmates and so
getting up to you know five something is
probably a good thing so what do we do
about that when it comes to manipulating
genomes I don't know we're gonna have to
debate these things and come up with
appropriate guidelines for doing this
kind of Technology
responsibly and see what um consensus
opinions are so most areas are pretty
black and white what you should and
should do but there probably are some
gray areas
great thank you
and then can this technology be used to
increase the telomerase for longevity
yeah good question
um
probably I think it's debatable whether
increasing your telomerates is the best
way to increase your longevity it may
increase your chance of getting cancer
because your cells May grow
uncontrollably so there are other
there's a lot of interest in those
longevity space just a ton uh people are
putting billions of dollars now every
year into new startups around longevity
it's one of the hottest areas and so
there's all kinds of strategies some are
anti-synalytics meaning trying to
um you know get rid of your senescent
cells it should say senolytics not anti
to get rid of your senescent cells which
might help there are programs you know
improve your your caloric restriction
and other sorts of things so it's not
clear what the right solution for this
whole area is at some point Christopher
will play a role in this but we don't
know how to solve longevity I'm not
ready to get my to 11 hours longer there
is a report of someone who actually
stuck telomerase
in in herself to get a higher expression
you can Google it up um I personally
wouldn't do that but um that seems like
you could be making cancer for yourself
uh but um anyway so we've we've just
there's just too much learn in the case
of longevity great great question though
another question here is there are
regulations and ethics in the medical
medical community what are your thoughts
on being able to order a crisper kit
through the mail there isn't any
regulation on what these people are
cooking up in their garage and an
additional comment is I took your
genetics and genomics program and it was
fancy
okay well that's how you knew how to ask
that great question there I guess uh I
don't know what to say yeah you know
there isn't regulation on this stuff and
should there be uh I mean I I just don't
think people should be sticking with
stuff into themselves or other people
right now for germine changes or again
without there being a life-threatening
condition it just doesn't make any sense
uh uh and so I I think all the stuff
you'd want to to work with uh you know a
research team and your physician to do
again do this responsibly I I know that
seems like a cop-out answer but I I
think it is the right answer we just
can't have people doing garage genome
editing
I think that'll be a design yeah who
knows I'm sure people are going to do
the stuff they're already cloning dogs
and stuff and cats more cats than dogs
actually but um
so
what are the different Delivery Systems
um technology to get the Guide RNA and
protein into the cell is our next
question yeah so I mean for research
people usually put the cas9 in first and
then bring in the guide separate but but
for these therapies it's really these uh
lipid particles these nanoparticles I
mentioned before they're very
specialized that's a bit turns out to be
a big deal people don't appreciate this
the key was to make these lipid
particles so that they were not
immunogenic that's a relatively recent
um breakthrough and that's what led us
to be able to make these mRNA vaccines
they're they're actually embedded in
these lipid particles and that was huge
because then you can stick them right in
you don't have an immune response
generally to them or at least not a
severe one
and and that's how people are doing it
now and um you know targeting the
specific organs that gets a little
tricky if you're working on muscle you
can try and eject directly in the muscle
you can try and put receptors on the
surface of these things to get in the
right place a lot a lot of things that
people do they they do them on skin
because it's accessible they do them in
the eye because you can inject in the
eye and there's a lot of pretty
debilitating diseases in the eye and
it's also immune protect you don't have
to worry about your immune system
blowing up at you if you start doing
manipulations in the eye it's immune
protected as I say and then the liver is
another area believe it or not because
if you stick things in people's
bloodstream it usually goes right to the
liver so these are some of the most
common areas that people are trying to
to fix and again that gets around
accessibility these are organs that are
accessible uh should be able to
manipulate
um for skin people have been
manipulating you know people put like
botox on on their skin and on skin and
stuff and it's uh
um it's you know that's a Nancy toxin
but it's okay it's sort of okay uh I'd
watch it a little bit myself but um it
you know it your skin turns over every
few days so you can actually it's an
area that you can modify and if you have
a you know debilitating issue like
psoriasis or something it's not a bad
area to manipulate so so those tend to
be the most popular systems people are
going after you know how do you
manipulate the brain that's still a
tough problem
okay
our next question is why would you use
crispr for DNA versus RNA and is there a
more Curative reason to use one versus
the other
yeah so people often like it's a great
question people often like the RNA
because it's Transit uh so imagine
you're not as sure about the therapy you
could actually and especially if you're
curing some of the blood diseases you
could actually you pull out some of
these stem blood stem cells you add the
the RNA which can often it's adding an
RNA if it's a what's called a recessive
disease you would add the RNA and it
complements you can see if it works and
everything looks good for crisper you'd
use the cast 13 system if it's a
dominant mutation try and destroy it
probably have to get a good copy around
of some sort so
um it it and and then you're not it's
transient you're only they're going to
be around for a few weeks or a few
months those cells they're not going to
completely
you know bugger you up permanently so if
something's not working
uh you'd figure it out kind of quickly
and right away uh whereas DNA
manipulations uh you know when you
repopulate stem cells and stuff they can
get permanent and certainly if you do it
in the germ line obviously you're making
a person who's permanently changed if
you do it if you manipulate an embryo so
the implications are very different
um and there may be but if you're trying
to hit every cell in the body you may
have to manipulate the embryo in order
to get it to work on every cell in the
body uh and and for certain diseases
that will be essential but for other
things like blood disorders you just
have to manipulate the these stem cells
in your bone marrow that's where your
stem cells are so the strategy very much
depends on the particular disease this
is a great question and you really need
the experts in those areas to actually
design a system for you know fixing it
in those specific cases
great thank you
um the next question here is any utility
for using crispr for curbing
anti-microbial resistance in pathogenic
bacteria
yeah great question so what's I I
literally this morning came from a talk
where people were using bacteriophage to
try to wipe out pathogenic bacteria
and they didn't use crispr they didn't
need it because
uh it's all natural but what's kind of
interesting they they could probably
improve it by using crispr but it comes
from a crisper concept which is a
bacteriophage come in uh and and destroy
the bacteria and they pick fish in a
certain way that would actually say they
come in through a
um a a transporter a drug transporter
they might bind that transport and then
get internalized so what happens is
resistance always comes that's a problem
with these pathogens are they so many of
them uh by numbers that they resistance
always pops up antibiotic resistance
you've heard about Etc so what's kind of
cool about this bacteriophage therapy is
that it can actually
um when it's coming in through a
receptor system or transporter system
like I said the the so we'll try to get
around that by when it gets resistance
it'll make a
strains that actually don't they're
they're mutated in that transporter and
then they actually don't become drug
resistant or kick the drug out so it's
kind of this might be a little
complicated without showing a diagram
but it's pretty cool that you can
actually use bacteriophage to actually
try to wipe out pathogenic bacteria and
then you come back with antibiotics it's
a one-two punch that seems pretty
effective
and so or it has been effective I should
say so early days I suspect we'll be
able to make that even better with a
manipulated versions using crispr and
stuff and I mentioned before the HIV
stuff I think I'd be surprised if that
doesn't work at some level where you as
I say and it's being trials are on that
using ccr5 where you delete the AIDS
receptor so age virus can no longer bind
those T cells and they multiply and they
do their job just like T cells should do
uh for boosting your immune system so so
I think for HIV it'll be a big deal
we'll have to see about you know can you
manipulate in humans other uh receptors
for pathogens for Dengue virus all these
sorts of things that's not clear it'll
be very very interesting
I think we have time for maybe one last
question here um the last question is
what is the advantage of the D cas9
version of the protein if it cannot cut
the side of Interest
uh for the D cast nine
um well
you can oh I know what you're saying
yeah so you can use it it's used a lot
in research
um where you and it could be used in
Vivo too it it it shows you actually
tether it to a system where you can
bring in a repressor and turn off
transcription at a very specific Locus
for example so you can shut off gene
expression uh and so instead of cleaving
you're actually bringing in a repressive
protein that can turn off gene
expression or likewise you can actually
tether it in a way manipulate way it
brings in an activator
so these defective versions are they're
very clever tricks for being able to
manipulate the genome and gene
expression and it's conceivable you
could use those in therapies I think
people like the cleaner version where
you don't leave anything behind
um any crispr behind as well because
that
um again the um the the Regulatory
Agencies just don't like the idea of
exogenous sequences sitting there maybe
it'll start making immune reactions so
that could be a mess so it's better if
you can make it clean but for research
purposes these have been powerful
imagine too you have a gene family where
you have 50 copies of a gene it's hard
to go in and Target all 50 copies right
you'll never get there but if you have
one of these
um D cast lines Tethered to an inhibitor
it can bind all 50 copies and shut them
all down at once
if that makes sense see so they're
they're clever ways of using that
technology great question
and once again thank you for joining us
today we hope you have a great week and
we hope to see you again in our next
session and thank you so much Dr Snyder
for uh being with us here today
thank you been a lot of fun great
questions thank you very much